alright
ooh doo doo doo doo doo doo
doo doe
thirty two
do you know total todo no no
ah and you can tell that we're
on zoom away from our singing
you are the fact that i said
zoom me that i my walk scott
did you say zudem i did say
zoomed them i'm sure a little rascal
one moscow zone i'm one of the
original little rascals wow that's your thousand
years old
are any of them still alive they're
all dead right alright hope i hope
alfalfa is did you whoa no they're
all dead yep you don't have any
got alfalfa carl schweitzer do you know
d sawyer as gonna say his hair
speared into a holiday couldn't get out
yeah i think it was a skeleton
no wow he's like the rhino
from spider-man the film what really happened
much like the primo from spiderman um
he was
with depth
over a gambling
ah it's kind of funny because it's
like what year was it
ah he was eleven now
no i think it was in like
the the fifties or something but that
would be he was eleven no no
no because those movies were made like
yeah they were already thirty years yeah
they're from the thirty going going there
from almost one hundred years ago
a thirty don't think i knew that
yeah they're ancient i think i thought
they were from the fifties are we
coming up on the one hundredth anniversary
of the little rascals the centennial eyeing
oh now is the time to celebrate
them how are we going to celebrate
we owe here are we here threesome
want to celebrate the centennial we're gonna
do rascals he has
we're gonna do we're gonna do a
rewatch podcast
realign summers we know it's so rewatched
we were all experts we we apparently
were part of it and we will
talk about every single episode every movie
in the new iterations and i wanna
save a more dreary thing to do
when i was evil when i was
a kid i didn't like them i
liked them they dealt him new one
sir
when they had dairyland choosing
everyone had a crush on darla and
she used her powers to manipulate them
this is why representation matters because laura
likes darla that's right there's something fucked
up though about this being a five-year-old
that everyone thinks is the best cutie
little cutie pie like that must be
confusing it was it was really difficult
for me
yeah i didn't mind it
welcome to freedom by the way yeah
oh yeah oh yeah oh you know
i have everything i wanted to bring
to the table but oh you're bringing
something to the tape like wait is
this is this new business it's new
business among business company in the minutes
yeah oh my god the last time
we had lawrence topics it was so
so momentous it was earthshaking what happened
we announce that you are having a
baby last time okay wow forums topics
as lawrence topics it's certainly the one
you're talking about the most oh my
god i'm sure i have more topics
than you've brought up topics since then
but we've never had lauren's top
pics since then so she's very exciting
yeah always thrilling welcome you on incomes
yourself yeah my name is william scott
freedom lauren my name is zoom paul
i guess my name is xu more
and i mean
look i we had to be on
zoom for personal technical difficulties and you
just have to accept it so or
if you could be speed racer for
one day where would you drive what
does he drive like really really really
fast yeah lauren wait are you like
would you run errands is that right
what i wanted i'd go to the
good target at the empire center what's
the thing you can't do in your
regular car that you could do if
you had speed racer's would drive to
new york in one minute wow that
would be awesome it's his car that
fast probably not how about the about
the flash well i mean if he
lived if he lived a minute away
from new york it would be
oh my gosh on the oscars everyone's
talking about it but i want to
talk about it some more when they
showed the flash entering the speed force
do you know how weird that was
considering there was a lifetime achievement award
handed out we didn't see that but
we watched clips from movies randomly smattering
over the years i was like what
am i looking at this like a
matrix flip they they they didn't really
announce what they were
are they just like no wrote these
clips up on the screen and they
were a health road that they throw
them up on the screen they trod
them they drove him up on the
screen ok i wanna i wanna i
wanna talk to you about this okay
lawyers is actually this is officially lawrence
topics this is it's a twitter thread
lawrence topics it's not oh yeah i
don't know i don't know that it's
vile
rural yet um it led me to
the card it has a lot of
likes but it's not really killing it
in the tweets and the number is
rising to cards catchphrase about making twitter
threads viral yes
okay mel that like and subscribe button
a person i follow
who is part of generation x which
is your generation retreat for agree quote
for no
decent generation ooh ne
no padres g on the left-hand side
okay the dude that was on it
that was the soundtrack she's starting right
which which sound direct possibly awesome powers
is that possible whenever one doesn't do
it a lot it's possible okay i
think i have those soundtracks and i
don't believe it's on there google it
but you
you know what i have to say
lauren i was very proud when you
came in with the next line because
i thought it would just be me
and paul doing stuff we know and
meanwhile paul didn't know what we were
talking about i never do wow passing
every single time i've been playing along
i'll actually is guessing but he guesses
ninety seven percent of the things right
yeah lee sin to me
um this is what i want to
talk over you about gen x okay
you are part of gen x am
i right whose i know i am
who's jennifer x ah it's jennifer lopez's
maiden name this is a thread aden
after before she married george lucas
so rebecca metz who somebody that i
follow who i've done many shows with
it at usb she cheese sounded off
on this as a generation x member
in the comments yes she said i
too assumed this dude was full of
shit and he knew i would think
that this is quite good actually ok
so this is what
he thinks about generation x this is
a guy named michael gurley at girly
generation x is weird these forty two
to fifty seven year olds are so
strange presents golden opportunities here are ten
mind hacks to use with gen x
o mind hacks
like hacking into our minds to control
them is out yeah what he said
yeah dumb don't mind hack me bro
before we start i'll be generalizing not
every genetics will think this way especially
yes especially those gen xers born in
hc either born closer and aged either
boomers born nineteen forty six to sixty
four millennials weren't nineteen eighty one ninety
six but these tricks will work with
most lets go these trips bring gender
ex hates what you do when you
do this but there's no law against
one trick one motivate gen x with
two phrases do it your way and
don't sweat the rules many checks grew
up in divorce single home parent homes
so they were forced to be self-reliant
and unsupervised early on they want independence
to get it done their way you
don't relate to that one no never
heard the story about people
right now yeah ok next one send
your genetics colleagues well written emails gen
x grew up with email but before
ss or apps their teacher stressed correct
writing too poor grammar drives jacks nuts
no
people older than me say the shortest
weirdest emails also we've gotten like i
understand that one but we've gotten so
used to that kind of communication that
it's like it's not yeah the thing
my my my mom when she texts
me does like abbreviations that i don't
even know what they are so does
my mom just makes up abbreviations your
mom
ah oh we're getting a late breaking
we're getting a late breaking interruption from
chevron whoa
chevron has led us know that past
the dooce was on the wedding singer
soundtrack i did listen to that wang
singer like it was kevin throw in
the chat the soundtrack playlist of the
wedding singer
although wedding singer i was thinking of
my best friend's wedding i was thinking
oh no no no no no no
no no no no no no i
don't think the jazz singer is my
jack number three pairs the two and
left hands yeah hey lie
huh
by nag number three acknowledged gen x's
emails quickly they will love you gen
x wants to know who is responsible
at all times they grew up when
institutions weren't too interested
it's not about my sounds wait with
the whirlwind email and institutions weren't to
just a word to be trusted we're
not yeah yeah unique time my intact
number we were trying to figure this
one out though okay so so corporations
are bullshit mtv is bullshit oh my
god i will
e-mail right away you like so yeah
corp i don't how do i know
who to trust someone who emails me
back right away yeah i know right
a corporation stand but i'm not genetics
everyone likes being emailed back right away
no i like it when the email
sits for a bit because if the
write me back right away then i
have to write back right away well
that's the thing yes if i'm asking
if i'm asking a question and i
just need a definitive answer i want
to get it right away but if
it's an ongoing conversation first of all
i will be so slow team either
instigate or vi to the initial email
and and then the shame builds up
and then i have someone sitting in
my inbox for like weeks weeks weeks
and i'm like oh lord let's flip
like that paul right no matter what
you're doing email okay right they then
they get shamed yes they get jade
okay we want to put the shame
on them not on yupo put the
shame on mame i have not ah
open
an email without saying i'm sorry since
i think two thousand and two wow
love that it's the mind hack number
four focus with gen x admission and
results not seniority effort or hours worked
you'll often hear jack say if someone
gets the job done in half the
time that's fine what i do say
that a lot
remember when we were just saying the
other day paul i was like hey
paul if someone gets the job done
and half the time that's fine yeah
and i was like you took the
words right out of my mouth i
was about why would someone not want
that i don't because they want argue
about seniority
okay fine see now this this to
me raises questions about other generations that
i guess i didn't i wasn't aware
of that there's what some generation it's
way into arguing about seniority well like
boomers might want you to work all
the hours to get the thing done
whoa are we giving boomers these genetics
mind hacks oh no no no
we can't get bluffing huh the micro
boomers and to them melendez no no
no no i don't want any boomers
listening boomers turn off this show if
there's any boomers listening to this and
we've we've done a poll of our
oldest audience members youtube better turn this
off right now we've done a good
job of pruning the boomers from the
show got pretty the boom
okay mine tag number five allowed x
a balanced life jack scrub with workaholic
boomer parents seeing that gen x things
work is part of life but not
why why they live so what okay
well my generation doesn't want to work
as the you know is what kim
cardassian woodson exactly she works hard she
works so hard
how is it a mind hack like
allow them to have a balanced life
who are you in this scenario yeah
this is a tip for me so
what i'm gonna do with this is
go i shouldn't always talk to them
about work i should i should talk
to them about what are you talking
about us ah
i also i also think that these
mind hacks should be for gen z
only okay well here because they're they're
more simpatico with us mind hag members
six bond with gen x as individuals
not as part of a tribe millennials
or institution boomers institutions from government to
marriage showed they couldn't be trusted during
gen x's youth even though you trust
them you're gonna kill me
you gotta understand that they don't find
there's too many here i'll skip to
the twentieth too long didn't read ah
number seven be direct number eight acknowledged
they exist
expect pessimism and number ten expect to
work life separation you know i learn
i first of all i think you
have acknowledged that's got an exist and
i that's much appreciated i try hello
we might be segments of your imagination
yes other people might not i don't
know i'm more i've been worried about
that but i think you're
real or what if you found out
that that show we did the other
night you were the only person on
stage i would honestly believe that it
was one of the most surreal experiences
of my life but it was in
retrospect or you know in watching it
i felt like it was um really
fun yeah not that it wasn't retro
nomadic was fun no i mean i'm
saying
once in a moment it was very
odd we should describe what we did
we performed um at dynasty typewriter theater
with no audience again but we had
the cameras roving around the theater following
us to different locations we did all
the scenes were just super weird because
we were like in these we were
it was just a different it was
just differ
it was just different and i really
liked it it had a ground breakers
yeah little yellow and different and what
we do is we shake up the
systems and we break the paradigms which
is very gen x and it's very
real yeah well it's a combo of
the two generations yeah the normal places
are not to be trusted so i'm
glad you didn't perform there that's what
i had
to tell lauren i was fired because
i consider it work to do a
show with you but i also consider
it like but it's kind of perfect
for me because i like workload and
i want to thank you for allowing
me to have both work and life
yeah i really am glad i was
able to do that for you yeah
show was it was it was a
job but i was also alive yeah
it was really interesting though with the
camera guys because when i watched it
back they were doing stuff that i
didn't realize there was a part i
don't know if you saw this part
like when we're in the oh really
we're flipping us off
where they were sitting behind us it
was it was a the back of
our head yes yeah that was cool
yeah i really liked it a lot
yeah i liked a lot to him
when he was french overs yeah it
was scott do you um want to
be in it yeah there were dirty
does he wants to be puyol knew
he did admit it yeah he did
admit it
oh wait that wasn't an invite you're
just wondering if you know oh
you can be our special guests we
use the gen x mind hack on
you stupid oh what's that you fucking
boomer
there was a comment when i was
watching it back because they show like
on the livestream you can when you
watch it later you can see the
comments that were floating in real time
and there was one that said i
understand why scott says no i saw
that and i was like i say
oh my shit eat my ass hole
where the shit lives
my asshole dry you think eat my
shorts the famous quote of bart so
was that ah that was like ah
so bernie damn it yes whoa i
never thought about that i thought that
was rude enough i thought that was
really my short what's ruined half a
cow supposed to be oh what's what
room and clout and power route rumah
callahan
what's don't have a cow michaela don't
have a cow man why what is
that i mean it's like that's just
great writing yeah it's like the typical
expression is hey don't have a baby
about it and then if this president
who are y'all like said we don't
have a baby well that's what we
were we ride to them yeah
that's what we were hoping with you
lauren is that you wouldn't have a
whole baby about this so well i
couldn't help it or do you know
lauren and i hope i hope this
isn't weird to say but i was
hoping you would give birth to like
a lamb baby like in the movie
lamb look there's a chance that could
happen there's i think one of the
weirdest parts about being pregnant is that
you cannot fathom
that there is an actual baby that
well it's because like it's there should
be like little windows on the stomach
yeah and they think willows will evolve
and we'll get there where the stomach
is clear so we could like look
in there and go like oh that's
what you look like before yeah absolutely
we have windows on the soul you
know yeah like eyes yeah exactly i
just the soul
oh yeah yeah what if there were
just like each age some eyes in
your belly button chicken soup for the
teenage exactly did you read chicken soup
for the soul no i did not
i feel like i had the teenage
one someone gave it to me for
some weird reason i can't remember why
you are bumming them out because it
was the nineties oh right
and they were an unimaginative person
every day in the ninety someone who
would give you chicken soup for the
soul yeah yeah i feel like that
book like there are certain books that
just scream that time period and another
one is don't sweat the small stuff
or something what does that one yeah
yeah and it's all stuff yeah exactly
spoiler um bridges of madison county
yeah eat pray love is what it
says i'm like the last page of
what to expect when you're expecting don't
sweat the small stuff and it's all
small stuff joy of sex the joy
of sex i'm curious if the bible
has anyone read the joy of sex
so can you tell me all the
spoilers our bodies ourselves
did you ever like look one of
those books when your a kid i
my friend had a puberty book that
we looked at and it was like
you that ebook
it wasn't puberty but
you put the puberty onto my book
show
about puberty into my boo
i just remember one of the key
things it was all drawings that looked
really seventy s yeah um love and
one of the key pages that stands
out in my memory was the one
where it showed all these different women
and their different colored cubes oh nice
yeah what were the debt let's list
the colors they're so waxing yeah like
sin
and ember and red and green and
levy why did they think did it
were they'd like trying to like don't
worry it'll match well because if you
were in the locker room or something
then you're like she's got red boobs
and then you're like you know you
couldn't make the connection that she had
red hair
it's nice oh yes it's case they
dye their hair well and then you
know secrets about them it's really back
i mean you know what i don't
know it's just the only page i
remember
yeah i already told you about the
book that my parents had yeah like
your poop collection
yeah it's stressed into a book yeah
now the one that was all about
sex and that and know that the
the the hack that they gave to
a one who'd just got married is
about to have backs and has to
have oral sex for the first time
as to imagine the penis as a
little tiny version of the of the
man that's the worst advice
nice that's like in my well know
and said they don't be loud we'll
know it's gonna be gross and that
you know snag hundred taxes they're sucking
your husband's whole body
imagine you're a giant test and you
will have is life in your hands
you could swallow him whole and shit
em out that's so sad it's really
weird just the idea that now of
course no one could ever enjoy this
it's impossible and you're gonna have to
do it hey it's this is one
of them pleasantness of life
remember i've told you i've told you
guys before about the book of lists
which was a favorite book of mine
when i was a kid that was
a big eighties book was right what
was it a list of i can't
remember it was it was a collection
of lists it was just like all
this was one long list know the
book of it wasn't the book of
list
um and it was i tried actually
after we talked about it this is
like season one i wanna say oh
i i've found ah hardcover copies online
i was going to send them to
you whoa and then they just never
came and i had to chase the
people down for a refund they're like
oh yeah sorry we didn't have those
books like maybe you gotta told me
it was like months and months that
is crazy yeah it wasn't a chase
and it was disappointing news disappointing where
did you find them the books
no the people that you chase down
they were only stealing
zero insane i was about to fall
asleep and i looked up and i
got you
during my moneymen has books i might
have told you about this but during
the pandemic which rages on i ah
i think it's over yeah hey yeah
completely over i ordered this i saw
this instagram ad for this really big
squishy steel like the animal and it
was like wait obviously you've missed
one i've seen yes yes yes like
a big stuff so it looks like
a big squishy pillow they show like
a kid laying on it and it's
so big he looks so happy and
yeah everyone loves it and everyone's squishing
and stuff and i think families gathered
around this what's gonna make my blur
a plot endemic ram puts on her
glasses absolutely so i ordered it and
it took
a long time and then one day
i got a package in the mail
and it was a very tiny white
plastic i ripped open and it wasn't
the seal it it was a piece
of shit carnival toy that was like
so small it was nothing to do
with the images that they oh my
but did what did they just find
the tiniest human and put
yeah so yeah picture i mean it
was a pure scam and i was
pretty upset but was also kind of
hilarious
did you get money back from it
or were you just know i got
like twenty bucks and it was like
it came from very far away and
i was there's just no way i'm
ever gonna track down this situation so
i just i just ate it i
wonder how many other people did this
i'm sure so many people it was
so funny when i was just you
and they're like we got wyoming burn
the factory down
this trunk when an accident they sent
it to me
well thank you buyer beware i'm glad
i know not to bore you but
then i've seen them on different sites
and they're like real yeah so it
was like somebody just use maybe you
just something your dad maybe you didn't
order the right one you should order
another one i should order it again
to see what happens
one thing that's really funny is like
stephanie allen um always messes up the
size of things that she's ordering so
they're either huge or really small and
it's just very funny show like get
an order in the mail and it's
like ten times bigger than what she
thought it was very small anyway that's
there there are many i love stories
like that when you see people post
them that they
accidentally ordered doll furniture whatever yeah i
can't believe this office chair such a
good deal
and they will take a picture of
it in the space like
it's so good the best one was
emily heller had ordered a welcome at
those supposed look like out was supposed
to be astroturf and when she got
it it was just printed a picture
of astroturf onto
ms garbage oh my god this is
why we don't trust institutions lauren yeah
you're gonna end the whole thing yeah
my bag for me we had a
columbia records and tape club and now
i dig i didn't use that oh
did you really just stay round campy
know we ordered from that when we
were kids and i don't know who
whoever i don't i think it was
a penny i don't think anyone ever
paid like it was like we got
unless we like put my parents' credit
card and we're know you never had
to put a credit card in right
so how did that they would just
they would send you bills through the
mail it was like they would and
then you just never paid them yeah
and but i i feel like they
would go through collection agencies or somehow
you know but like using your address
i should
asked my parents they remember because i
remember we got some seat we got
cds like a few times for a
penny which ones were filled when i
recall his jurassic park soundtrack and little
mermaid soundtrack i said oh so when
you when you were a kid you
were listening to the jurassic park soundtrack
and he's going gone oh no no
no no no no really cheap on
the left
ah these generations where you like someday
i'm going to be in a movie
with those fucking dinosaurs well that was
um we did use to dance around
the living room to that nadia put
my brother on blast but um that
is that's why i took them to
the premier because it was very fun
it was like very surreal we were
like walking in it was like so
the music playing so awesome
very exciting yeah genie calling ms cool
jays calling paul di di di di
di di di di di james calvillo
put it on speaker i want a
divorce oh i'm so sorry i'm reporting
freedom right
well yeah a kid towards you i'm
not kidding you i'm so sorry and
here's their nose parking on the street
no sparking nope on the street yesterday
so i'm moving away
hold on one second hold on one
second fuck you what was that
fuck you too
hey jay love you johnny who don't
you
one problem
oh hey guess he was good too
she was cracking up
love janie
i do too love that woman lover
love her to bits love her those
little tiny bits hey speaking of little
tiny bits we have to take some
little tiny bits of commercials and listen
to them now now okay let's see
what happens let's see what happens just
see i mean it's a grand experiment
we may have a little tiny bit
so we might have just a little
gloopy bloop i don't trust institutions would
trust these ones because they're smart enough
to advertise on this nah nah nah
nah nah my
and we're back i know i am
i'm also present and guys i went
to the dermatologist today oh no skin
graft yeah it was i was getting
that face off surgery good where they
were going to take your face off
that's the
very same yes whose for the switch
wit on yeah with ah who's that
who sang um i dreamed a dream
on that one show i dreamed a
dream and hathaway
oh i wish oh my god no
susan boyle
the biology was ugly but you could
see that was her whole thing i'm
so high is that if we talked
with this but how fucked up was
that that everyone was so fucked up
she walks everyone's like yeah right like
she's gonna be able to sing okay
way ugly poo this old bag and
she's saying they're like holy shit oh
fucking shit
say like kill myself they purposely dressed
her down and everything they put her
in like a brown sack yeah yeah
is it smeared mud on your face
that will dry out in disgrace
two big guys emptied out a garbage
can she came crashing out of it
like she was like i was sleepy
and you're like lettuce were falling on
her head right from the collodion where
they slimed her oh so i'm the
body and header oh it stinks in
here and she wants me that's not
doing this waving
their hand in front of their nose
the adobe called steamy stink loins
okay so i went to the dermatologist
what they tell ya so ah first
of all very very did you get
diagnosed as butter face
i'm asia butter face
no it was almost the op was
about because oh the opposite they said
you are so handsome but your body
sucks
huh
body face your body fit
hey dr butter your butter body
no so i'm wearing a mask but
i'm in my underwear and that you
know
was it me andy's as told by
cool up on her eyes told by
as revealed by
but so the doctor walks in with
someone else who's just kinda like hanging
his girlfriend and he's like hey about
you after dinner because like you're here
ask
ah
your ass i said see ya she
said oh can i get your escrow
i'm so sorry your asked crack dry
as an appetizer
she's
it was always like he's like okay
you're here from mole check alright great
it's like cai fora
yeah that's good click nice
hey you have any holiday sauce allergies
do you
flat lower
so he's like so he's like okay
you're here for will check um okay
i'll check this was good it was
me doing the balls
oh hey what what
so you like looks everything over he's
like this looks good i just want
to set the listener to use everything's
fine this was good this was good
this day he goes okay take off
the mask he's but by the way
he's like so what do you what
do you do for living i'm like
a writer i always say writer because
it's like easier than you don't want
to get explaining podcasting or anything like
that and it doesn't sound like fancies
so people
so like ah he's like oh what
do you do for me i'm like
oh writer so things like ok take
off the mask i take it off
and goes oh
so handsome no and i'm like i'm
like i started laughing ago okay because
you you should be in front of
the camera wow this is a dream
you had
i was laughing it was like so
over the top like he was lying
or was he wearing a mask ah
yeah i think so i should cut
off his scott that was me once
that was gone yes i wanted to
boost yourself esteem he was wearing a
lone ranger mask yeah me too
where we were no oh no
um but who is the other person
and what did they contribute i don't
know and then and then at one
point there were three people in there
i'm just like sliding why no dangling
look at his face ah but it
was it was really like i was
like hey this mole i don't know
if it's gotten bigger i just like
i want to come in and he's
like
it's fine as like so it's not
it's not a concern he's like
i'll just take it off
right now what isaac yeah when they
just got he's like yeah yeah then
they shot here you go ernie rips
it off with his bare hands they
shot some stuff into it into it
and then he just like then and
then so he's he's about to do
it i think he's trying to distract
me from from what what he's about
to do which yeah i see he
has like a razor blade
beaten his hand did he numb it
she's like
yeah it looks like yeah and so
it's like a sick so he's like
i loathe it hey what do you
think what do you think of ah
will smith
i'm like what do you think it's
like what you think of this slap
i'm like a slept or mole off
i go i go like i don't
care and he goes well i think
it's i think it's good because because
you know you shouldn't make fun of
someone with a medical condition ago and
that's why you should slap someone he's
like yeah it's good right i go
i don't care yay
i think i don't care as the
only response it doesn't situation like that
you can't get into it because you
could be there all day yeah because
no i think it's good i think
i think he should have done that
i go yeah i don't really care
if he goes okay okay you're done
thought it was good what if you'd
said ah what about first do no
harm oh the golden rule so so
so will smith the definitive with a
medical condition but he chooses to slap
a man
what would equities say doctor i did
get a good one in on him
because yeah he he made he made
me wait an hour before seeing me
in the waiting room and when when
he heard i was writer he was
like oh are you going to write
a ah movie about this and i
go oh yeah the first hour is
gonna be me sitting in the waiting
room yeah
that's fuckin solid and and then he
was like oh let me validate your
parking since i made you wait so
long
it was like they weren't going to
why don't they just do that all
the time why is it yes that's
the thing about doctors they make you
wait so long but the good news
is we won't validate your parking yeah
when you go to any kind of
medical place where they're like yeah we
don't validate parking it's like how can
you live with yourselves yeah why why
don't you just wait commit suicide right
right now yeah well in front of
me it's just like commit hara kiri
having to pay to park in a
parking structure is already kind of stupid
for the antiquity building yeah it's just
for one this is the earth that
we all own yeah let me park
wherever i freaking please yeah but you
know they park ah like kind of
all
over the place in iceland really on
you can kind of like you can't
block the street but you can kind
of just like you know like sort
of put your car half on the
sidewalk or whatever you love it weird
angles you know what yeah it's funny
when you see angles yankovic
weird like the angle like finland or
something i think it's finland people just
put their babies in the stroller outside
the cafe or whatever like they just
line them up and the babies in
the stroller and you just go inside
and you do your thing and then
you come out and take the baby
let's wait and a bunch of babies
are sitting out there by themselves and
do they make friends with each other
i don't know and i don't know
necessarily why you would really want to
do that but i thought it was
interesting how safe it is i would
love to come upon a line of
babies in strollers in front of a
cafe yeah and you haven't imagined love
that every once in a while one
gets swiped oh god damn like okay
it's like a guard
oh taken no not like a credit
card every cafe has one baby guard
who's there he's like the buckingham palace
guard but that guard is also a
baby yeah and a different stroller that
was red
but he isn't charged you are loren
are people like i mean maybe you're
not out there in these streets all
that much but like dude do people
give you an unwanted advice ever um
you're like like bossing you around your
stuff like that well like so i
flew to atlanta for work with
if mike and holly in november and
the second we got off the plane
ah and atlantean woman santos and was
like she was like she was very
southern tip you gotta put socks on
that baby it's it's cold it's cold
out here and then we are like
oh okay um we
we're about to or whatever and that
was kind of like one of those
like the first time i'd ever been
talked to like you need to do
this for the right and then when
we walked into the baggage claim mike
was just standing next to me and
holly and then mankind was like you're
a great father
let's see da he's not but it's
like ignoring me completely like we need
more guys like you your and then
like mike was like why oh thanks
he came back and said no you're
great father you're here you got the
baby you know baggage this is a
guy with daddy issues himself yeah if
that's a classic thing though right it's
like the dads that get the chalk
write it dads oh
yeah my mom's classic thing um like
yeah i feel like i see it
online a lot there's a lot of
instagram things like yeah yeah dig dad
gets praise for like doing one thing
like yeah super dad because well even
drier yeah yeah exactly
but you know it's great deserve it
it's great to get it everyone's great
it's just it's perk everyone's great everybody
great people say what they want it's
fantastic i love it i would find
it you get it when you have
dogs enough like other dog owners going
like oh hey you need to do
this with your dog yeah yeah really
yeah i did i was not aware
of that what would they say you
need to get your dog out of
my house stuff like that who let
these dogs out
it was mainly the baha men were
really upset with us those guys were
huge
but um i remember one time we
watched a television show it was maybe
like the dog whisper or something like
that where like one of these houses
like hey you know instead of constantly
bending over and using your your hands
to like correct your dog or whatever
you can just use your feet and
tap tap the dog with your feet
and like like if if he's going
trying to go forward just stick your
foot out and block him and stuff
like that and so we were trying
that one day and this couple like
pulls over to the side of the
road and shouts out their window and
goes you shouldn't kick your dog oh
my god and then squeals away and
all you can think of to say
in the in a situation like that
is fuck yeah
yeah yeah yeah exactly but then you
look like someone who kicks their dog
yeah and screams fuck you passing motorists
what if what if you had screamed
hey likes it
he's already following the training combat sermon
last earth
but you get that a lot when
you're like you know dogs interact or
whatever you get like bossy dog owners
going like oh no you haven't trained
your dog properly yeah here's how here's
what you have to do um no
but i definitely know that people get
a lot of unsolicited advice know yeah
it's worries worst it's worth it for
a baby no it's worse for babies
what and that's it yeah i haven't
really had that but
you know the other day i did
take her on a long walk in
path shorthair and i walked for a
long way around like just very populated
you know there's a lot of um
restaurants people sitting outside all sorts of
thing a man selling ice cream yeah
and everyone was smiling and waving at
her and they were so happy to
see her that i was like this
is great like i just like i
i felt like everyone was like oh
my god and then i would turn
lie with they would they'd be like
oh my god all weapons one was
like she's picture perfect it was just
like an audible oh yeah it was
my doctor is they're saying
take your mask down like you're somewhere
else oh yeah yeah i would have
that reaction if i saw holly i
didn't know holly and i saw her
on the street while chileans pushed around
stroller and titanic's bow on her head
and she was actually brushing it were
you worried when you put the bow
on her head that someone would think
she was a present and say oh
my god thank you so
much and yeah few people did try
to open her
does minnie mouse still have a bow
um horse teen jumpsuit now or something
i think right what did they change
to j changed her outfit and people
were like up in arms now she
wears a lab coat she wears what
the green eminem used to wear just
boots
she's naked she's nude with white boots
she's wearing a chocolate shell she looks
exactly like micky right but they just
wear different clothes is there any other
issues eyelashes she has eyelashes yeah there's
a crucial difference and and technically she
has a vagina underneath everything you could
never see it but you get down
whenever see
yeah mickey's penis for that matter yeah
you just know yeah i mean they
fit together pretty well she's kind of
a size queen they don't have kids
oh speaking besides why don't they have
that kind of cute their little mice
i'm sure yeah they should there's like
there's like baby miki bay many like
those in the next hundred years let
them have kids please please please please
bring us an heir year bring us
an heir speaking of size queen though
my my shimla are cool
gonna divorce fucking my sister la know
my sister law i was i was
getting from a mattress and i sent
her like a website ah ah where
she could pick the mattress and she
she writes back and says here's the
link i want size queen and i
was
like why are you calling me a
size queen i literally was like reading
going like oh fuck are you oh
hey cool up cc honest i'm like
what joke is this i don't
i finally read it and was like
oh she wants the size queen of
the mattress
oh i'm a size king here's the
link size queen
so sorry i did not get it
for so long did you tell her
yeah yeah i wrote back i was
like i literally thought you were calling
me a size queen you have to
call each other that forever from now
on
oh way to make kevin kevin is
kevin sent us another link oh well
thanks ice cream to treat oh it's
just the threesome games oh okay haven't
we thought this was like a link
to some size queen thing
fun sideways forum oh there must be
sized queen memes do you remember like
when you first got online and you
were looking at porn and you're waiting
for it to load waiting for the
load when you're waiting for like a
picture of heather locklear to start
we're likelier we didn't have we didn't
we had posters that you could buy
yeah yeah i mean that's a pretty
great situation just have a post over
a hot babe on your wall and
you're just like every single night like
there's my girlfriend
i mean if you're really serious you
put her on the ceiling you know
sigh huh yeah jacket off so sick
um lauren when you were when like
would you try to look up naughty
things when you were a kid um
no enter you when you had the
internet in your life um i think
i was like ten when you
good first release started in like middle
school was when we were really on
aol yeah but i don't recall trying
to look up things like that but
i do recall being in chat rooms
where you would have conversations like that
with people and that was always very
exciting having a sleepover party and then
you basically go online like um just
say crazy shit
two strangers
it was very fun but i mean
you know presumably most people were like
also kids doing that but there's the
gross reality that other people were not
yeah yeah that's it is funny though
to think of like little kids all
doing that to each other yeah it's
so funny it's so we're less familiar
penis any spell your peanuts
yeah well you do a ourselves you
know a a salt like a slash
american sign language no age sex location
so you'd be like oh you'd be
like twenty three you like sixteen f
florida and then just like let the
party roll yeah let the party roll
did you ever meet anyone for real
or was
it's just crazy show no but um
i did like i told my mom
like one day i was like i
made a friend online and we're going
to be pen pals when we use
our address homes like oh um but
not nothing happened with that thing god
but by definitely had friends who did
equally like i
i had friends um not like people
who i'm friends with now who we've
talked about this stuff and they told
told me that they met up with
people in real life like dangerous kind
of things that happened like your parents
we didn't know and like you go
meet up with someone it's like so
scary no good dude did you have
internet friendships that carried on for a
long time like people yeah there were
a couple of people that's
really funny i don't think about it
much they were comfortable that i did
and didn't ever know who they were
but it's like someone that i met
in a chat room or something and
then we talk all the time um
and then it's just like you feel
like you get to know them pretty
well um and then there were certain
people from school where you wouldn't only
talk in person but you would talk
online as it was like you were
more like
chat buddies and then in real life
like either you were too nervous or
there was like weird chemistry or like
whatever but it's like we were but
you're really good online like maybe they
were assoc yeah so it wasn't like
a secret kind of relationship or was
it no more just like this doesn't
translate to hear like i don't know
wow school
metaverse we are great yeah yeah oh
but it was always fighting with those
people when you'd be like get online
and be like chatting with someone and
yeah just spend our whole lives online
after school get up get online and
instantly see huge signs on and you
know we got bullied online all sorts
of shit went down i mean the
three of us have a text chain
which is sort of like this you
bullied
me on it yeah and i feel
more comfortable talking to you there then
scott you're the biggest bully on that
text chat widely know it so me
your mean this is how me nine
hey when should we record again i
know it's so shitty of you
but you're not describing the little gift
sticker that you attached which was a
middle finger oh that's true should we
take a break and come play with
reacher i think we i don't know
i'm i've really been weighing this decision
yeah i i was talking to my
pastor about this this morning and saying
i knew i knew this moment was
gonna come up is going i was
like what
should i do and he told me
to pray on it and what god
told me i think
was that we should take a break
and then come back and play reacher
okay so that actually like god spoke
through you i've i mean it's not
like i didn't hear a voice or
anything but i yeah that's the feeling
that i have after praying on it
yeah i mean i pride night i
disagree but i'm outvoted at this point
so well should i talk your pi
put up
a poll on twitter um begging people
to tell us whether we should ever
take a break boy yeah i'm begging
you no one will respond to this
below votes no votes so vote and
so i just know i have to
go with what you guys say so
i'm just going to go with okay
break yeah right ok thanks god alright
god will take your break all right
god
we'll be right back
and we're back and it's time for
a three cheshire lauren and these oh
no we're not back i haven't like
agreed to be back and i've actually
texting your pastor to ask if it's
okay ah yeah i'm not back i
never said that i would come
back oh my god
just a different guy
what are you looking at oh i'm
a grownup ah i was wondering ah
we doing call it's how much underwear
do you have your hook
the one pair who
what joke is that you just go
oh yeah
oh look it's like there's this third
age where kids don't have a grasp
on
how did i what constitutes like a
crank call yeah just not meaning what
you're saying constituted it's just like getting
somebody to say a thing that you
think is naughty yeah um right what's
the game scott alright well this please
you know people submit these somewhere i
don't know where but three team usa
jailer come okay sure whatever you say
paul um and this hey don't humor
me whatever you say well whatever humor
go with a boomer whatever you say
boomer but if you're saying gen xor
um this is called this by the
way this is submitted by ben okay
we don't have a last day in
the
no we both found wood we were
to teaching losing star michael jackson our
old buddy ben
it's about a rat named ben
it's he it's the it's from the
movie willard which is all about oh
okay all about crispin glover being yeah
friends with oh but it's no but
it's from the original willard no yeah
michael jackson singing in the future one
time i was i forgot about crispin
and i told the story know what
i don't know help in in
then we'll tell you chris lover it
all started rogers spinning it christmas album
revolutionary war deja vu about chris yeah
because i was trying to say crispin
and i was like crispin crispin glover
crowded wrong and i just felt like
that happened in before maybe this is
all happened before um buys shit but
i witnessed him talk about a money
issue on the phone with you i'm
issue i was sitting in like a
room
waiting to do an interview with mario
lopez yeah wait he was interviewing you
or you were interviewing him he was
interviewing me oh that's so quinn would
interview mario lopez i'm sorry how's interviewing
oh i would ask about se but
laval um but i was like i
was hitting the room
i was sitting in a room waiting
to go do it and then he
was crispin it was like pacing outside
the room talking about some money trouble
not not money trouble but like a
problem that was i feel like you've
talked about this very rude i do
that's right then recently but okay someone
will that's why you have deja vu
i think because i remember if i
remember it
you need to retake money out of
checking and put it in savings if
crispin glover's name comes up i'm mentioning
that story that just smelling a story
about him but he's so good back
to the future you so good and
so good on letterman i'm struggling i
can kick yeah the letterman he's wearing
a wig yeah there was a famous
letterman clip where he ah was
yeah on purpose and he kicked in
the air and it was very close
to dave's head and then he was
banned from the show for a while
love it he basically letterman just like
stood up and walked away and then
when you came back he wasn't there
anymore
and crispin glover took over the show
and it was his show for about
seven years it was wild they still
call it lane over david letterman yeah
but with crispin glover yes um okay
this is called money please
money please and we're going to have
to get our phones out and text
each other because oh fuck i love
these one of us is a parent
who is short on cash and can
only give one of their two children
their allowance this month the other two
are going to try to convince the
parent to give them the money
by explaining what they plan to spend
their allowance on however what they want
to purchase will be decided by the
other players so the more absurd the
better um players make their pitch to
the parent whatever child the parent decides
to give their money to wins okay
what is that again
john i opened my phone and i
fell into it yeah so did i
yeah clearly i'm spiraling into this i
glad you said hundred texts and yes
like i read them
i didn't do it in layman's terms
thank you these i've been laid were
gonna take turns being the parents say
i'm the parent right now okay you're
the parent i can only afford to
give one of you your allowance this
that's not good so i'm broke where
the children yeah you're the children you
guys are going to petition me and
say what you want to use the
allowance for
oh great this is a lot like
king lear okay so i ever shakespeare
who assigned we assign each other the
thing that we want yes so like
you have to assign each other a
a stupid thing but then you each
have to passionately defend why you want
this thing and i'll decide who ah
who i give the money to based
on
on the merits of your argument i
like because this is a meritocracy this
is a meritocracy yes i will not
be ah basing this on your gender
or your race now you guys are
reading your texts no i'm texting you
know i'm texting i'm trying to think
of a thing i know
oh man genie's texted a lot on
our other thread she's really this what
you fell into
did it calls done it paul's locked-in
me lauren has texted me and now
she's texting someone else i've got it
okay all right our children children daddy
joe's daddy we love you we love
your daughter i love you the most
study do you know a children's study
i love
your daddy i love love most
i love your daughter i need to
know the lengths and boundaries of your
love chill i need them allowance for
me daddy daddy i did the allowance
i love i have that all southeastern
yesterday wow those are all the directions
i have bad news i love you
to the who what where wide howl
the reporters yes
that's a dirty word what is a
problem not to what what does the
people without the i got laid off
of work as you know i got
yeah would've been great if i'd stop
there was no that's often worth to
note that the daughter i got laid
off at work children know letter at
the at the factory factory at the
factory factor we've we make so many
factories how many factors like no one
wants to lay off one once factories
anymore i made three hundred thousand factories
but no one wants to work the
day no one wants to work kim
kardashians right people need to work harder
and just work bitch yeah thank you
you look bitch the data do tell
you to wait what does this mean
yeah what about load stuff now i
could split i have i have only
enough money for one allowance i could
split that into twain and get taffeta
oh and acceptable today but okay cause
my thing is too expensive okay so
i'm going to give as well i'm
going to give you one of you
your allowance but i need to
no it it's media d it's me
to do yeah but i really got
to know are you gonna go my
way
politico aesthetic
what do you think his blended family
with jason momoa first of all daddy
okay this doesn't look i need something
very big daddy okay with you you
the small is a very important thing
for me what a hard pretzel subscription
hard pretzel subscription what what okay tell
me
tell me what you would need this
i will receive a hard pretzel and
o harm a different region how hard
very hard sour dough hard that hard
but sometimes not so adult because it's
only one month so how many pretzels
do you receive per month every month
i get one just one and how
big very very small
like a rolled gold pretzel like a
rolled gold pretzel daddy plea how much
is this ohio the bricks my teeth
and you broke want romance oh and
child daddy a year's subscription is my
allowance for one month well that's a
good value as one year for one
month
uhm
it's very tempting and why i've never
seen you eat that's why do you
why do you want pretzels just about
a block up talking to her but
she's take that it's what year of
her allowance for one month of pretzel
know the opposite you waste one month
of the allowance and get a whole
year because each pretzel is so small
little birdie and they're being so
sent by little nicer mouse company that
loaded with its weight so it's a
mouse company not a pretzel company they
collect pretzels in their little mousehole and
they send them out monthly that's ok
okay so wait is it is it
a technology company is there an app
elon musk is the star the sata
show didn't show business terms for ceo
know he's above the line this is
a done deal with some fucking money
okay chit you you you they'll be
old one study that don't meet the
allowance i need the reality check and
high school bell a school bell
yesterday a school bell a school bell
what do you mean like the kind
that that says when you're later when
you're yesterday then i can control the
classes i can decide what happens that
they needed that the pleased that the
man was not meant to play god
the dead they have not a man
of a boy nobody noticed nothing in
the playbook that says oh my god
air bud rules for children and god
please dare they please that day what
would you like to know what would
you do is that they would make
it so that the classes were all
one minute long day and the school
day would be over by eight thirty
that's very tempting for you perhaps but
i would have to babysit you the
rest of the note that didn't know
you wouldn't because we would just hang
out in the school until the regular
time that school ends but we could
do whatever we want that day and
what do you want to do instead
of what to stand on the desk
and do a poem that day which
still exactly
walt whitman oh captain my captain daddy
please daddy please i think the body
electric daddy you would do so you
would do those dirty limericks i've been
hearing you recite please daddy the woods
wasn't that lucky daddy i would like
to see what happens next study daddy
i need the aloud study for the
power and you
needed for power and you needed to
break your teeth and then i'm gonna
make teeth jewelry and sullivan fc oh
this sounds like a good business plan
and i'll make my allowance back with
interest
people seven point nine percent financing no
not that what about the big the
vague
the juice
she just tell me who is the
money daddy website what's your very patient
child identity what's at the school but
like i can make the principal and
see how the teachers are not working
all that long and then he will
try to buy the bill bag for
me i'll make like my dad will
be so hard you think the principal
will go by the bell from your
child
yes the principal will buy the bill
and i will mark it up like
nobody's business what if the principal buys
his own bell child he can't do
it that they can only be one
bell daddy there's only one bell in
all of your city yes daddy the
school bell daddy are you buying this
bell from the school yes daddy why
did they put it on c
because they kicked it down the money
from the allowance daddy daddy tell us
again how much our allowances it's ah
thirty five cents a minute ah per
second okay lasting for one second
you
a year yes child
daddy please daddy daddy give give give
daddy give that to give give you
meaning into me who wins dat who
dat who do you love more this
is not a who do you love
more contest child we don't this is
literally kill you daddy you do you
are george thorogood
good idea who do you love this
is very difficult because you don't seem
to understand what's going on and you're
threatening you is god's will but children
daddy i'm going to kill you with
my knife can i have some of
the pretzels stab oh go i'm slain
you've done it parentheses dies
oh no he died so fast
quick open his pockets oh look how
much money and on the math comes
out to know he has no money
it doesn't even have thirty five cents
to our daily daddy he was alive
he didn't even come back he's very
him trim in the tub let them
bleed out fire
and we did it ah fun stuff
what a blast i bet it's okay
that there was no decision in the
end i think so too i think
it was great that your character passed
and you think that was really happening
he passed away passed
neto causes i could i love you
both equally i couldn't decide so sweet
life imitates art wow art imitates life
you guys i have to tell you
i'm so tired that i have to
go eat dinner it's nine o'clock and
i'm starving lauren i don't play nine
slog i'm honored and hearing your whining
wow wow
around until next week when we'll hear
your whining some more now
um this was a blast and a
half and i hope everyone goes and
follows us on instagram and twitter at
three am usa and you can oh
you know what you can also do
is go get our show that we
wanna watch it at the video vol
ten days typewriter that's right lauren and
i did a show for an empty
theater roving cameras following us around it
was a lot of fun and
it's up there now dynasty typewriter dot
com scott of course we'd love him
and when he's not there we miss
him yeah and if you want to
hear ad-free versions of this show yeah
yeah you go ahead over to stitcher
premium or cvb world dot com yeah
yeah yeah yeah um and um
and um leave us a voicemail or
some oh yeah leave us a voicemail
where we're going we're going to right
now record the voicemail ah measures so
you'll hear it oh yes so you'll
hear it we'll post about it just
follow you'll hear it alright we'll see
i speak to you later bye sweeties
what what are you holding up that
we can't read this oh the book
of lists there it is it's blurring
it
it's blurring it like like it's says
fuck you
blurring my foreground oh me i'm lowering
my foreground there we go the book
of lists the book of lists there
oh i love it thirty five minutes
i'm gonna track down copies for you
guys okay i hook or by crook
by tonight
like buy dinner shit
alright bye bye
a